aujourd'hui j'aurais quand même ce que
c'est avant noël et
il ya plein de français qui peuvent pas
fêter noël et je voudrais les mettre en
lumière ce soir parce que c'est vrai que
la crise sanitaire s'est rapidement
doublée en crise économique il ya plein
de gens qui travaillaient tranquillement
qu'ils étaient heureux qui arrive est
bon à joindre les deux bouts et qui se
retrouver sans rien pour nombreux
français ce noël
je vous jure il ya plein de gens qui ont
l'angoissent de noël d'habitude tout le
monde dira c'est noël on va se retrouver
on va être heureux voire cadeaux et ce
noël
il a un goût particulier tous les gens
plus on approche des fêtes de noël plus
ils sont en bois c'est parce que ils
peuvent pas acheter de cadeaux
ils se disent on peut pas aller voir
notre famille il ya plein de gens qui
vont être seul pour noël et je vais
recevoir ce soir parce que vous avez été
des milliers à vouloir témoigner je
voulais avoir ce soir une personne qui
témoignent parce que y'en a plein qui
vont se reconnaître en elle c'est l'audi
elodie et sa famille sont dans une
situation très compliquée on voulait
absolument avoir son témoignage parce
que vous voulez avoir le témoignage de
français qui ne pourront pas fêter noël
cette année
regardez petit récap de la vie d'elodie
regarde dans moins d'une semaine l'heure
sera venue de fêter noël
un rendez vous magique qui rime avec sap
un cadeau chocolat et moment de partage
en famille
en moyenne le budget total des français
pour fêter noël et de 603 euros un
budget en hausse de 50,3 euros par
rapport à l'année passée qui comprend le
dîner les cadeaux et l'organisation de
l'événement pourtant ces périodes de
fêtes où chacun attend son cadeau et de
retrouver ses proches certains n'ont pas
cette chance
envieux des cadeaux cette année ne
dépassera pas 100 euros alors que les
années passées il était bien supérieur
une inégalité encore plus difficile à
supporter en ce moment pour beaucoup la
crise sanitaire actuelle s'est
transformé en véritable crise économique
perte d'emploi ou baisse de revenus
certains ne s'en sortent plus les
chiffres sont formels en raison du coc
vie de 19,1 millions de français
supplémentaires se trouveraient
aujourd'hui dans une situation de
précarité des français comme elodie 41
ans maman de deux enfants est sans
emploi
elle est avec nous ce soir pour nous
raconter les difficultés
et quelle rencontre elodie est avec non
merci d'être là elodie je voulais
absolument avoir un témoignage ce soir
voilà ce que je dis je le ressens il ya
plein de français qui se disent cette
année noël c'est pas la fête bien au
contraire il ya une angoisse de voir
noël arrivait quand on a des enfants
quand on a des familles ont dit voilà
cette année comment je vais faire pour
pour essayer d'acheter des cadeaux il y
en a même qui s'endettent à fond pour s
essayer d'acheter des cadeaux à leurs
enfants et elodie vous vous avait
basculé dans une certaine précarité
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et j'ai perdu
mon emploi
en fin d'année 2010 9 et puis avec le
pot vide quoi ça a été difficile
impossible de retraite vous retrouver
seule avec deux enfants en bas âge
jarod hui vos objectifs professionnels
impossible c'est ça mais quand il était
petit oui c'était compliqué parce que je
comptais j'avais le projet en fait
d'ouvrir une société de tout ce qui re
organisation événementiel sauf que je
venais de me séparer donc il était
encore petit donc ça commence à basculer
déjà là et puis après bon j'ai eu un
choc quand j'ai eu d'autres tentent ils
ont repris l'école qui notre boulot en
fait
alors quand on est dans une situation
difficile et plein de gens le savent
il faut faire des choix vous avez décidé
de vous priver de quoi vous avez vous
avez privilégié vos enfants forcément
amer mais c'est que vous venez d'arriver
vous de vous priver vraiment d'eux mais
on vit pour nos enfants donc quand on
fait les courses mais un premier cd
enfin si on est s'il privilégie moi
j'essaie de privilégier pour pas les
coupes et socialement qu'ils fassent
quand même du sport voilà mes mais là je
le chômage et 900 euros sur europe 1
avec deux enfants
seul donc autant dire que c'est la
trousse grosse galère et pour noël
ça va c'est pas pu encore acheter de
cadeaux et une période terrible
notamment fin 2018 vous pouvez pas payer
votre loyer 2019 vous êtes licencié vous
savez même pas comment vous allez
nourrir vos enfants j'ai en fait pendant
trois mois je n'avais plus de revenu et
j'ai pas pu payer mon loyer pendant
trois mois j'ai eu une procédure
d'expulsion
donc j'ai dû passer au tribunal voilà on
m'a fait un un échéancier et puis fin
fin 2010 9 ans j'ai été licencié et
et pendant le pot vide là la crise
pareil j'ai eu à manger pas qu paie mon
loyer parce que je démens j'ai mes
enfants
et voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
compliqué on a tous temps l'angoissent
savoir son impression paraître nous
n'avions rien à manger où vous avez mais
pas mangé pendant certains soirs vos
enfants manger du lait ducey et des
céréales il ya des vos enfants c'était
un stress permanent aussi et il paraît
que vous aviez honte de croiser vos
voisins à l'est voisins
il faut nous à l'école parce que moi
j'ai fait aussi un burnout à une
dépression jeu
quand on passe la journée à pleurer a
pas savoir comment on va faire on est
moins et arrive un moment où j'arrivais
même pu aller chercher mes enfants à
l'école
donc j'ai garé il faut pas voir le
visage des autres parrains parce que
c'était compliqué pas vous êtes
célibataire sans emploi vous habitez la
fos sur mer vous avez deux enfants enzo
et thiméo et ce soir j'ai envie que vous
passiez noël un peu plus tranquille que
ce qui était prévu
je sais que les cadeaux ça va être
compliqué pour les enfants et j'ai
ramené un cadeau ici
elodie pouvez l'ouvrir et il y à un
cadeau pour vous et vos enfants
regardent alors qu'est ce que c'est
vous pouvez sortir je crois qu est-ce
que c'est un billet d'avion au dubai ou
partez jamais parti en vacances tous
partis à dubaï et nord avec vos enfants
sinon nous partons à dubaï avec vos
enfants vous êtes heureuse twill merci
regardez yab aux enfants qui sont là on
va les convaincre et enzo et thiméo et
voyez vous partez à dubaï avec vos
enfants
ça va mais chéri d'amour oui il est
content de partir à dubaï oui alors
juste vous savez eux
moi je crois qui en fait se regarde et
je crois que ce cadeau en fait il ya un
double fond regardez j'ai l'impression
complet on peut soulever ici
et regardez ce qui a je crois qu'un
autre cadeau pour vous un an de loyer
que vous avez beaucoup de mal votre
loyer
et bien pour 2021 c'est réglé on vous
paie et votre loyer pour 2021 pour les
enfants et vous ma chérie je voudrais
remercier s'arrête dans un hôtel de rêve
un le séjour à dubaï hôtels de rêve en
famille et je voudrais remercier la
compagnie des émirats primé est reconnue
vous serez en toute sécurité pour aller
voyager et un nom de loyer julie c'est
pour nous mais je crois en plus
dernier cadeau je sais pas j'ai
l'impression qu'ils aient un dernier
cadeau ventes et où j'ai l'impression
qu'ils encore un fond là-dedans faut
respirer
comment vous allez je sais que c'est
vous qui amené mes enfants à l'école
tous les jours c'est compliqué j'avais
la voiture en panne
i
je sais je crois qu'il ya une dernière
je crois qu un dernier cadeau énorme sur
l'écran s'il vous plaît pour sûr
électrique d'une valeur de 30 à 1000
euros
superbes voitures mg 100 % électrique à
l'hérétique j'en rêve moitié de ses
moteurs je rêve d'une valeur de 30 mille
euros ces voitures mg motor 100%
électrique je vous dis que je l'adorent
je suis fou et c'est de cette voiture
regardé l'avant et nous il est
magnifique c'est c'est le suv du moment
il est à vous je tiens à remercier parce
qu'une particulièrement monsieur liu
le président de lens n incite jo briac
dany bar qui ont été très touchés par
votre histoire
mg motor qui vous offre cette voiture
allait savions et bien sûr je voudrais
dire tous cas dans le coffre à tous les
cadeaux et bien bien sûr c'est pour les
enfants aussi et pour noël vous partez à
dubaï vous avez la voiture vous avez un
nom loyer on espère que ça va vous
remettre en selle alors on peut pas
aider tout le monde mais on a été touché
par votre histoire merci on voulait
absolument vous et dès ce soir elodie
elodie je vous souhaite énormément de
bonheur à vous et vos enfants mais qui
reste que vous êtes content pour maman
pour vous êtes contents les chéris des
bars moi aussi je suis très heureux pour
vous je suis très content pour elodie
elodie vous souhaitez énormément de
bonheur je suis ému et merci du fond du
coeur surtout matin déjà des cha et ça
c'est pas facile pour beaucoup de monde
donc pour tout le monde en fait vraiment
merci parce que ce sera vous adorez pour
goûter
j'espère que là vous allez que qui fait
les chéris je vous fais des normes busy
merci énormément même fort et mercy qui
fait bien et audi team et ong d'avoir
est allé que je joue avec lui c'est
cadeau assez pour vous les chéris merci
d'avoir été un peu les applaudir et
merci encore lg motors parce que cette
voiture est les voitures d'une valeur de
30 mille euros et un cadeau exceptionnel